the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi last time we had discussed series and
sequences today we're going to turn our
attention to a rather special situation
a situation in which every term in our
series is positive for this reason I
have entitled today's lecture positive
series before we can do full justice the
parts of the series however there are a
few topics that we must discuss as
preliminaries the first of these is
simply the process of ordering and this
is a rather strange situation because in
the finite case it turns out to be
rather trivial by way of illustration
let's suppose the set s consists of the
numbers 11 8 9 7 and 10 now there are
many ways in which we can order the set
s we can arrange them so that any one of
these five elements comes first any one
of the remaining four second etc but
suppose that we want to arrange these
according to size observe that there is
a rather straightforward shall we say
binary technique whereby we can order
these elements by binary I mean let's
look at these two at a time we look at
11 and 8 and we throw away the larger of
the two which is 11 then we compare 8
with 9 throw away 9 because that's
bigger compare 8 and 7 throw away 8
compare 7 and 10 throw away 10 the
survivor being 7 is therefore the least
member of our collection in a similar
way we can delete 7 and start looking
for the next member of our set and in
this way eventually order the elements
of s according to size 7 8 9 and 11 okay
clearly 7 is the smallest element of s
and 11 is the largest element of X and
in terms of nomenclature we say that 7
is a lower bound for s 11 is an upper
bound for you see in terms of a picture
all we're saying is is that when the
elements of s are ordered according to
size 7 is the furthest to the left 11 is
the furthest to the right we can even
talk
more about the nomenclature by saying
and this sounds like a tongue twister
this is why I had you read this material
first in the last assignment in the
supplementary notes so that part of this
would at least seem like a review
observed that seven is called the
greatest lower bound for s simply
because any number larger than seven
cannot be a lower bound that s simply
because seven would be smaller than that
particular number and in a similar way
eleven is called the least upper bound
for s because any number smaller than 11
would be exceeded by eleven and hence
could not be an upper bound for s now
the interesting point is this hopefully
at this stage of the game you listen to
what I've had to say and you say my
golly this is trivial and the answer is
it is trivial but remember what our main
concern was in our last lecture when we
introduced the concept of infinite
series and sequences that many things
that were trivial for the finite case
became rather serious dilemmas for the
infinite case in other words my claim is
that these results are far more subtle
for infinite sets and I think the best
way to do this is by means of an example
see now let s be the set of numbers
where the nth number is n over n plus 1
in other words the first member of S
will be 1/2 the second member 2/3 the
third member 3/4 etc now let's take a
look to see what the least upper bound
for s is and sparing you the details I
think you can observe at this stage of
the game especially based on the
homework of the last unit that the limit
of the sequence s is 1 in fact 1 is the
smallest number which exceeds every
member in this collection in other words
1 has the least upper bound for s but
observe the interesting case that here
and by the way notice the abbreviation
that we use in our notes Lu be least
upper bound gl be greatest lower bound
but 1 is the least upper bound for s yet
the fact remains that the least upper
bound is not a member of s itself in
other
there is no number n such that n over n
plus 1 is equal to 1 you see notice that
as these numbers increase they get
bounded by 1 but 1 is not a member of s
in other words here's an example where
the least upper bound of a set does not
have to be a member of a set and the
companion to this would be an example
where the greatest lower bound is not a
member of the set and to this end simply
let the nth member of s arranged by
sequence be 1 over n the nth member is 1
over n therefore s is what the set
consisting of 1 1/2 1/3 etc observe that
as the terms go further and further out
they get arbitrarily close to 0 in size
every one of these terms 1 over n no
matter how big n is is greater than 0 in
other words then observe that 0 will be
the greatest lower bound for s but 0 is
not a member of s in other words it
seems that things which are quite
trivial for finite collections have
certain degrees of sophistication for
infinite collections so what we're going
to do now is to establish a few basic
definitions and we'll do it in a rather
formal way our first definition is the
following given the set of numbers s M
is called an upper bound for s if M is
greater than or equal to X for all X in
s in other words if M exceeds every
member of s M is called an upper bound
for s ok as I say these these
definitions are very straightforward the
companion well let's go one step further
by the way observe that I have in the
interest of brevity left out the
corresponding definitions for lower
bounds but they are quite analogous in
other words I a lower bound for s would
be a number that was less than or equal
to each member in s at any rate then M
is called a least upper bound for s if
first of all M is an upper bound for s
and secondly if L is less than M L is
not an upper bound for s in other words
least upper bound means what anything
smaller cannot be an up
bomb notice in terms of our previous
remark that the least upper bound need
not belong to s okay the companion to
this would be what a greatest lower
bound would be a number which is a lower
bound such that anything greater could
not be a lower bound again all of this
is easier to see in terms of a picture
visualize s as being this interval with
little m and capital M being the
endpoints of the interval observe that
capital M is the least upper bound
little M is the greatest lower bound
anything smaller then little M will be a
lower bound anything greater than
capital M will be an upper bound and
notice that nothing in the set s itself
can be either an upper bound or a lower
bound because anything inside s appears
to the left of little m and to the right
of little m and to the left of capital m
and one final definition as a
preliminary a set s is called bounded if
it has both an upper and a lower bound
and the key property that we have to
keep track of throughout this and we
won't prove this in other words in more
rigorous advanced math courses this is
proven as a theorem for our purposes it
seems self-evident enough so that we're
willing to accept it and so rather than
to belabor the point let us just accept
as a key property that every bounded set
of numbers has a greatest lower bound
and a least upper bound in other words
if a cell is bounded we can find a
smallest upper bound and a largest lower
bound and this completes the first
portion of our preliminary material the
next portion of our preliminary material
before studying positive series involves
what we mean by a monotonic
non-decreasing sequence a sequence is
called monotonic non-decreasing and if
you don't frighten that these words it's
almost self-evident what this thing
means it means that no term can be
smaller than the one that came before in
other words the answer
is less than or equal to the n plus
first term for each N and woulding that
more explicitly it says what a sub one
is less than or equal to a sub two is
less than equal to a sub three etc and I
hope that it's clear by this time that
it's not self-evident that a sequence
has to have this remember the subscripts
simply tell you the order in which the
terms appear it has no bearing on the
size of the term for example in an
arbitrary sequence recall that the
second term can be smaller in magnitude
than the first term however if the terms
are non decreasing sequentially this way
the sequence is called monotonic
non-decreasing and the problem that
comes up is are the important question
that comes up is what's so important
about monotonic non-decreasing sequences
and the answer is that for such
sequences two possibilities exist in
other words either the terms can keep
getting larger and larger without bound
C in other words that the sequence a sub
n has no upper bound in which case we
say that the limit of a sub n as n
approaches infinity is infinity and for
example the ordinary counting sequence
has this properly see 1 2 3 4 5 etc is a
monotonic non-decreasing sequence in
fact it's monotonic increasing every
member of the sequence is greater than
the one that came before but as you go
further and further out the terms
increase without upper bound okay now
what is the other possibility for a
monotonic in non decreasing sequence
after all the opposite are the only
other possibility is that if the ACE
event if it's false that the sequence
doesn't have enough abound then of
course it must have an upper bound
that's the second case in other words
suppose the sequence has an upper bound
then the interesting point is that the
limit of this sequence exists and not
only does it exist but the limit itself
is the least upper bound of the sequence
in other words in the case where the
sequence is non decreasing if it's
bounded if it's bounded the least upper
bound
we'll be the limit now you see here's
where we use that key property namely if
a sequence is bounded it must have a
least upper bound let's call that least
upper bound L and by the way you'll
notice I wrote the word proof in
quotation marks it's simply to indicate
that I prefer to give you a geometric
proof here rather than an analytic one
but the analytic proof follows
word-for-word from this picture in other
words it just translates in the usual
way and we'll drill on this with the
exercises and the notes and the textbook
but then rate the idea is this to prove
that L is a limit what must I do I must
show that if I choose any epsilon
greater than zero that all the terms
beyond a certain one lie between L minus
epsilon and L plus Epsilon
now here's the way this works let's see
if we can just read the diagram and get
this thing very quickly first of all at
least one term in my sequence has to be
between L minus epsilon and L and the
reason for that is simply this remember
L is a least upper bound because L is a
least upper bound L minus epsilon cannot
be enough abound now if no term can get
beyond down minus epsilon then certainly
L minus epsilon would be an upper bound
the fact that L minus Epsilon isn't an
upper bound therefore means that at
least one a sub n say a sub capital n is
in this interval here notice also that
because L is an upper bound no a sub n
can get beyond here in other words no a
sub n lies between L and L plus Epsilon
because in that particular case if that
were to happen L couldn't be enough
about okay so far so good that follows
just from the definition of the least
upper bound now we use the fact that the
sequence is non decreasing and that says
what that if little n is greater than
capital n a sub little n is greater than
or equal to a sub capital n in other
words what this means is if you list the
a sub ends along this line as n
increases the terms move progressively
from left to right in other words notice
then
that if if n is greater than or equal to
capital n L minus epsilon is less than a
sub capital n which in turn is less than
or equal to a sub little n which in turn
is less than or equal to L and that's
just another geometric way of saying
that a sub n is within epsilon of L and
that's exactly the definition that the a
sub NS converts to the limit L now I
went over this rather quickly simply
because this is done in the textbook and
all I'm trying to do with this lecture
is to give you a quick overview of
what's going on well you see we're now
roughly 15 minutes into our lecture and
we haven't come to the main topic yet my
claim is that the main topic works very
very smoothly once we understand these
preliminaries the main topic you see is
called positive series and a definition
of a positive series is just as the name
implies if each term in your series is
at least as great as 0 in other words if
each term is non-negative then the
series is called positive now why our
positive series is important and why do
they tie in without previous discussion
well let's answer the last question
the reason they tie in with our previous
discussion is that we have already seen
that the that by the sum of a series we
mean the limit of the sequence of
partial sums to go from 1 partial sum to
the next you add on the next term in the
series if each of the a sub ends is
positive or at least non-negative notice
then that the sequence of partial sums
is monotonic non-decreasing why because
to go from the nth partial sum to the n
plus first partial sum you add on a sub
n plus 1 and since a sub n plus 1 is at
least as big as zero it means that the n
plus first partial sum can be no smaller
than the nth partial sum
in other words therefore if the series
summation n goes from 1 to infinity a
sub N is a positive series it must
either diverge to infinity or else that
converges
the limit L where L is the least upper
bound for the sequence of partial sums
okay now qualitatively that's the end of
our story in other words we now know
what for a positive series is a diverges
to infinity are else it converges to a
sum a limit and that limit is what the
least upper bound for the sequence of
partial sums the problem is that
quantitatively we would like to have
some criteria for determining whether a
positive series falls into the first
category or the second category notice
how can we tell where the series
converges or whether it diverges and you
see the reading material in our text for
this assignment focuses attention on
three major tests and these are the ones
I'd like to go over with you one
slightly so to speak the first test is
called the comparison test and it almost
sounds self-evident I just want to
outline how these proofs go because I
think that once you hear these things
spoken as you read the material the
formal proofs will fit into a pattern
much more nicely than as we haven't
heard the stuff set out loud you see the
idea is this let's suppose that we know
that summation n goes from 1 to infinity
C sub N is a convergent positive series
in other words all of these are positive
and the series converges suppose I now
have another sequence of numbers u sub n
where each u sub n is positive seats at
least as big as 0 but can be no bigger
than C sub n for each n then the
statement is that the series formed by
adding up the U sub ns must also
converge knows what you're saying is
here's a bunch of positive terms that
can't get too large and these terms in
magnitude are less than or equal to
these therefore what you're saying is
that this sum can't get too large either
and if you want to verbalize that so it
becomes more formal the idea is this let
T sub n denote the nth partial sum of
the series involving the C sub ends in
other words let T sub T sub n be C sub 1
plus etcetera up to C sub n
and let s sub n be the nth term in the
sequence of partial sums of the series
involving the use in other words that S
sub n be u1 plus etcetera up to u sub n
now the idea is look at we know that
each of the use in magnitude is smaller
than each of the C's consequently the
sum of all the use must be no greater
than the sum of all the C's in other
words the nth partial sum S sub n is
less than or equal to the partial sum T
sub n for each n now by our previous
result knowing that this series
summation C sub n converges it converges
to its least upper bound of partial sums
in other words the limit of T sub n as n
approaches infinity is some number T
where T is the least upper bound of the
sequence of partial sums of the series
well in particular then since each S sub
n is less than or equal to T sub n S sub
n itself certainly cannot exceed the
least upper bound namely T in other
words S sub n can be no bigger than T
for each n well what does this mean it
means then that s the sequence S sub n
itself is bounded well it's bounded it's
a monotonic non-decreasing sequence
therefore its limit exists not only does
it exist but it's the least upper bound
of the sequence of partial sums in other
words this proof is given in the text
all I want you to see is that step by
step what this proof really does is it
compares magnitudes of terms in other
words if if one batch of terms can't get
large if term-by-term
everything in another sequence is less
than these terms then that second sum
can't get too large either and this is
just a formalization of that there are a
few notes that we should make first of
all namely the condition that u sub n be
between 0 and C sub n for all N can be
weakened to cover the case where this is
true only beyond the certain point look
let me show you what I mean by this
let's suppose I look at the sequence 1
1/2 plus 1/3 let's do it this one 1 plus
1/2 plus 1/4 plus 1/8 plus 1/16 etc in
other words the geometric series each of
whose terms is 1/2 this series we know
converges ok
now what the comparison test says is
suppose you had something like this 1
plus 1/3 plus 1/5 plus 1/9 plus 117 etc
see notice that each of these terms is
less than the corresponding term here
consequently since these terms add up to
a finite amount these terms here must
also add up to a finite amount but
suppose for the sake of argument I
decide to replace the first term here by
10 to the 6th I'll make this a million
now notice that this sum is going to
become much larger but the point is when
I change this from a 1 to a 10 to the
sixth even though I made the some larger
I didn't change the finiteness of it in
other words if I replace the first four
terms here by fantastically large
numbers and then keep the rest of the
series intact
sure I've made the sum very very large
but I've only changed it by a finite
amount which will in effect not change
the convergence that's all we're saying
over here that the comparison test
really hinges on what beyond a certain
term you can stop making the comparison
and the second observation is the
converse to what we're talking about
namely if we know that u sub n is at
least as big as d sub n for each n where
the series summation n goes from 1 to
infinity D sub n is a positive divergent
series then this series summation u sub
n must also diverge since it's
convergence would imply the convergence
of this in other words notice that by
the comparison test if summation u sub n
can converged the d ends being less than
the un's would mean that summation d n
would have to converge also at any rate
these are the two portions of the
comparison test and this is what goes in
to the comparison test now the
interesting thing while the drawback to
the comparison test is simply this that
99 times out of 100 if you can find a
series to compare a given series with
you probably would have known where the
given series converge the diverge in the
first place in other words somehow or
other to find the right series to
compare something with is a rather
subtle thing if you didn't already know
the right answer to the problem well at
any rate what I'm trying to drive that
is that the comparison test has as one
of its features a proof for a more
interesting test the test that's far
less intuitive called the ratio test the
ratio test says the following let's
suppose again you're given a positive
series what you do now is form a
sequence whereby each term in the
sequence is the ratio between two terms
in the series in other words what I do
is I form the sequence by taking the
second term divided by the first term
the third term divided by the second
term the fourth term divided by the
third term and let's call that general
term u sub n let's this seems a little
bit abstract for you let's look at a
more tangible example suppose I take the
series summation n goes from 1 to
infinity 10 to the N over N factorial
notice that in this case the enth term
is 10 to the N over N factorial the n
plus first term is 10 to the n plus 1
over n plus 1 factorial so u sub n is
the ratio of the n plus first term to
the nth term in other words 10 to the n
plus 1 over n plus 1 factorial divided
by 10 to the N over N factorial 10 to
the N plus 1 divided by 10 to the N is
simply 10 and n plus 1 factorial divided
by n factorial is simply n plus 1 in
other words observe the structure of the
factorials that you get from the nth to
the n plus first simply by multiplying
by n plus 1 again the computational
details will be left for the exercises
at any rate then in this book
a case you sub n would be 10 over n plus
1 now here's what the ratio test says
assuming that the limit U sub n as n
approaches infinity exists call it row
then the series converges if Rho is less
than 1 and diverges if Rho is greater
than 1 and the test fails if Rho equals
1 in other words if the terms get
progressively smaller so that the ratio
in the limit stays less than 1 then the
series converges if on the other hand
the ratio in the limit exceeds 1 that
means the terms are getting big fast
enough so the series diverges
let me point out an important
observation here notice the difference
between the limit equaling 1 and each
term of the sequence being less than 1
in other words notice that even if u sub
n is less than 1 for every n Rho may
still equal 1 for example look at the
terms n over n plus 1 for each n n over
N plus 1 is less than 1 yet the limit as
n approaches infinity is exactly equal
to 1 now again the formal proof of this
is given in the book but I thought if I
just take a few minutes to show you
geometrically what's happening here
you'll get a better picture to
understand what's happening in the text
let's prove this in the case that Rho is
less than 1 pictorially if Rho is less
than 1 that means there's a space
between Rho and one that means I can
choose an epsilon such that Rho plus
Epsilon which I'll call R is a positive
number but still less than 1 now by
definition of Rho being the limit of the
sequence a sub n plus 1 over a sub n
that means I can find the capital n for
this given epsilon such that whenever n
is greater than capital n the absolute
that a sub n plus 1 all the a sub n is
less than Rho plus Epsilon in other
words is less than R where R is some
fixed number now less than 1 now let me
apply this to successive values of n in
other words taking and to be capital C
looking at this thing here taking m to
be cap
I have a over capital n plus 1 a sub
capital n plus 1 over a sub n is less
than R in other words a sub capital n
plus 1 is less than our times a sub n
similarly a sub capital n plus 2 over a
sub capital n plus 1 is also less than R
in other words a sub capital n plus 2 is
less than R times a sub capital n plus 1
but a sub n plus 1 in turn is less than
R times a sub n putting this in here
a sub n plus 2 is less than R squared
times a sub n at any rate if I now sum
these inequalities you see what I get is
what the limit as we go from n plus 1 to
infinity in other words the tail end of
this particular sum is less than what
well I can factor out the a sub n over
here and what's left inside is what R
plus R squared plus R cubed etc but this
particular series is a convergent
geometric series in other words this
must converge because this converges and
this is less than term by term the terms
over here in other words notice that the
proof of the ratio test hinges are
knowing two things the comparison test
and the convergence of a geometric
series again the reason I go through
this as rapidly as I do is that every
detail is done magnificently in the
textbook all I want you to see here is
the overview of how these tests come
about finally we have another powerful
test called the integral test and the
integral test essentially equates
positive series with improper integrals
by the way I have presented the material
sort of so to speak in the order of
appearance in the textbook you see the
comparison test ratio test and integral
test are given in that order in the text
and so I kept the same order here
however it's interesting to point out
that the integral test in a way is a
companion of the comparison test
and let me show you first of all what
the integral test says it says and I'll
show you I've written out the formal
statement here I'll show you pictorially
what this means in a moment but it says
suppose there is a decreasing continuous
function f of X notice the word
continuous in here that guarantees that
we can integrate f of X such that f
evaluated at each integral value of x
say x equals n is u sub n where u sub n
is the nth term of the positive series u
1 plus u 2 etc then what the integral
test says is that the series summation n
goes from 1 to infinity u sub n and the
integral 1 to infinity f of X DX
either converge together or diverge
together in other words we can test a
particular series for convergence by
knowing whether a particular improper
integral converges and to show you what
this thing means pictorially simply
observe this see what we're saying is
suppose that when you plot the terms of
your series see u 1 u 2 u 3 u 4 that
these happen to be the integral values
of a continuous curve y equals f of X
which not only passes through these
points but as a continuous decreasing
function as this happens then what the
statement is is that the sum of these
lengths converges if and only if the
area under the curve is finite and the
proof goes something like this it's a
rather ingenious type of thing you see
notice that if this height is u sub 1
and the base of the rectangle is 1
notice that numerically the area of the
rectangle notice quite in general if the
base of a rectangle is 1 numerically the
area of the rectangle equals the height
because the area is the base times the
height if the base is 1 the area equals
the height so the idea is simply this
look at suppose for example that we look
at this diagram over here notice that in
this diagram if we stop at n the area
under this curve is the integral from 1
to n I want to end plus 1 because of how
these lines are drawn see notice that
the first pi
stops at the number to the second base
stops the number three etc the idea is
this though that the area under the
curve in general from 1 to n plus 1 is
integral from 1 to n plus 1 f of X DX on
the other hand the area of the
rectangles are what u1 plus u2 plus u3
up to u n in other words for any given
end u1 up to u n is greater than or
equal to this particular integral
consequently taking the limit as n goes
to infinity we get what that summation u
n is less than is greater than or equal
to integral from 1 to infinity f of X DX
consequently if this integral diverges
meaning that this gets very large the
fact that this can be no less than this
means that this two must also diverge
correspondingly if we now do the same
problem but draw the things slightly
differently notice that now in this
particular picture the area under the
curve is integral from 1 to n f of X DX
on the other hand the area of the
rectangles are what it's u2 plus u3 up
to u n but now you see the rectangles
are inscribed under the curve
consequently u2 plus etc up to u n is
less than this integral therefore if I
add u1 onto both sides the sum u 1 etc
up to u n is less than u 1 plus integral
1 to NF of X DX if I now take the limit
as n goes to infinity you see this
becomes summation u n n goes from 1 to
infinity this becomes integral from 1 to
infinity f of X DX and therefore if this
now converges the sum on the right is
finite since the sum on the left cannot
exceed the sum on the right the sum on
the left must also be finite
consequently the convergence of the
integral implies the convergence of the
series
again I apologize for doing this this
rapidly all I wanted to do was to get an
idea of what's happening here because as
I say the book is magnificent in this
section the proofs are very well
self-contained at any rate this gives us
stream rather powerful tests which I
will drill you on in the exercises for
testing convergence of pauses of series
what we're going to do next time is to
come to grips with a much more serious
problem and that is what do you do if
the series isn't positive but that's
another story and so until next time
goodbye
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate